[Music]
so
have you guys ever cheated on an exam or
a test
in school oh yeah oh yeah how did you
guys pull it off
i just looked over like this and i
started marking what my friend did
that's the easiest way for sure i had
like do you guys remember those big
ballpoint pens like they were like
thicker that's a big-ass pink
okay from the carnival for camera you
guys remember those big bombs
[Laughter]
they were bigger than that actually no i
mean these belt remember
the bigger ones yeah they were bigger
yeah not that big but they were
the ballpoint pen you could put quarters
and you could save it from stuff no
no no not though but so the point is
that it was clear so what i would do i
would write the answers like on a sheet
of paper and i would put it in there
and then as i'm like doing my tests i'm
like oh [ __ ] i see my notes yeah i've
used erasers
i've used the pen trick i've used
writing it on my hand
i've also used it's so stupid
but i also use my my freaking sixth
sense
and what i know it sounds so dumb
it sounds really stupid but it's only
stupid if you don't get an a yeah true
wow that's a good point that's really
good
if these are six cents you got a hundred
percent that's pretty tight and we're
the stupid ones
isn't that just called studying and
remembering it no she's just not
studying
what's your sixth sense studying you
know
opening the book spending 12 hours at
the library
i memorized no dude i would literally be
this was like in like
third grade second grade third grade so
wasn't that developed yet the sixth
sense yeah
yeah yeah exactly it wasn't that
developed but i would do this with my
with my tests i would be i would close
my eyes
oh that is stupid can't even consider
cheating that no i'm
no but that's what i'm saying like
that's what i would use oh anyway that
was a hail mary
hover i would hover over every answer
because it'd be multiple twice
and i'd be like and i would have like a
tingly
like this like weird like it's a ouija
board of text like
it was like a weird ass like it's this
one
nope i would only do it for the ones
that i didn't know and
more times than not i would get those
answers right so i'm like
whatever it is it was working why don't
you
do it for all of them then oh because i
knew
the other answers because i i would know
the test but like the ones that like the
ones that i got
really like stuck on i'm like universe
please
can we i've definitely done that before
too it's not even close to cheating
and it's not cheating no well it's
cheating because i'm using the
universe's energy hello do you guys
remember that
well it's like a meme that's been going
around of this kid absorbing the [ __ ]
homework
yeah you flipped it an engineer
that one they put it in their bread put
it in their right side of their brain
that seems like something that's what
they're yeah they said you would do this
as a kid i'm like nah dude
like i'm not that stupid i used to write
it on the desk too that was the easiest
one
or even write it on your shoe you just
go like this you're shooting you're
gonna mess up your shoe
yeah i didn't have a lot of you're like
around your shoe you could ride on the
desk so you were just in the classroom
like this and people was cool with it
you gotta be slick about it footages
people printed out labels
and then they wrote it out in the back
and then you just look you did that yeah
water bottle labels so that you can see
through the water
because me the most cheating i did was
for formulas i don't remember the
formulas
like you had to kind of look at the
algebra formulas or whatever the
formulas and you go okay
sure once you have the formula yeah you
can plug and play or the easiest is you
just skip class that day so you're
sick and then the next day when you're
supposed to take your test
the teacher usually makes you come in
during lunch time because
they still have their periods and then
when it's during that lunch time
they want to take their lunch like i
just stay here for like 30 minutes and
take her test and he can fumble through
all her papers and find the answer no
way
wait wait they're not there they're
babies some of them are strict and
they'll have their like salad and
they'll watch you wow but it's not
a salad [ __ ] dude they were watching
their diet
they're always watching their diet well
i bring up cheating on exams because
apparently in mexico in the state of
michoacan
nice uh thank you 35 young women
were caught cheating on an exam and not
just any exam
it's an entrance entrance exam into a
school
for teachers so these are all aspiring
teams oh my god we're caught
cheating on an example were they using
the energy method and they're like no no
no no you can't summon the powers of the
[ __ ] ancient big world
there's like 30 people with the eyes
closed and they're like no no no no no
no cheating no cheating stop stop people
summon your ego powers my eager power i
think he's
being no no i feel hey no but i can't
see oh [ __ ] what is it man
no when you think too hard bart it's not
we gotta feel it you have to let it come
to you you can't force it
i see e i see
c c
but it's filling the blank oh [ __ ] just
put c there
the teachers are cheating on the
teacher's exam yeah the teach though
that the aspiring teachers
they were cheating on their exam and
this is how they got caught this is what
it looked like
oh [ __ ] on the nails i love the reveal
oh they're not eating salads damn is
that a more is that a morse code
so this is a color-coded like there's
different colors for different letters
so it is multiple choices it's multiple
choice and each nail has
uh 10 has 10 answers on it and there's
100 questions for this exam so it's like
perfectly on each finger there's ten
times ten there's a hundred how did they
figure this out that's some cartel [ __ ]
there's some cartoons you know the way
like cartels [ __ ] sneak drugs into
[ __ ]
and they got [ __ ] little signs and
[ __ ] like yeah yeah like this
[ __ ] cartel what is it a baseball
mouth i don't know that's some
damn that's crazy but yeah so 35 women
were caught
doing this but that number could be
higher because uh
so back in july they were conducting
july
yeah so back in july they had uh these
tests for
teachers to get into this uh school for
teachers
and apparently about 100
no no about 50 applicants ended up
scoring
perfect scores oh come on you guys
really when you cheat you got to be a
little bit off like 95 percent
that's the first rule they teach us in
cheating school gets them wrong
i was always the 93 to 95. it's very
safe well
well there's another 300 that thought
that and 300
teachers uh scored between 90 and 99
and it was irregular 100 that's a lot of
people
yeah they're all smart well it's unusual
because they caught this because other
municipalities so like outside of
michoacan
uh in other states of mexico uh the
highest score was 71. so are they saying
that they're just smarter or they're
dumber
uh i don't it was your regular how about
that we'll leave it at that i think it's
the biggest dish ever because they're
like
we know the people from each rock on
they're not that smart no
way they got it then that's pretty
[ __ ] up 93.
so apparently this is not uh officially
proven but
like through the rumor mill they're
saying these teachers are paying
between fifteen thousand to twenty-five
thousand pesos for the uh
answer sheet and i'm gonna go to my
mexican mexican uh
well now i mean the friend friend
friend no the way i calculated i just
remove a zero you remove a zero but now
it's not that simple because it changes
like crazy the dollar and the peso it's
like who knows
i think it's like i have a mexican
friend called google
what's that 25 000 pesos what what is it
25 000 pesos
11 158 dang it's so
off now back in the day you just remove
a zero and there you go that's how much
much time that's worth it though he paid
a lot of [ __ ] money for that thousand
dollars
to like for your career 25 000 right
imagine trying to pass the bar right or
the mcat or some [ __ ]
pay a thousand bucks you get the full
answer key well it's got to be relative
to the nation's economy though
right so right okay it's gotta be ten
g's for some people ten like maybe ten
g's here it's still worth it yeah
you think that's how much it would cost
to get the answer sheet for like the bar
exam
maybe but it's worth it because like
you're it's like you're you're setting
yourself your entire future up just
studying that's what i'm saying that's
so crazy maybe knowing these stats i'd
go for a solid like 83
just so i wouldn't get caught you know
yeah that's true one dollar
is like 20 something pesos wow that's so
it changed like crazy did it go about
higher low used to be like 10 or 12
i don't remember 10 pesos so the pace
got weaker yeah it got weaker
that's inflated oh yeah yeah yeah so and
this was in july
now in august on august 21st they they
redid
all the exams in the state uh and then
in order to
not have fraud no cheating put gloves on
everyone yeah like that's the only way
they're gonna cheat
they're gonna just write it on the glove
yeah now they could flip the glove over
though
okay poke their finger through the glove
yeah that's true you can like uh stretch
the material you know when you stretch
it it gets more uh
transparent but they have different
forms because that's like like
like cheating catching cheating
one-on-one like in college
it's like you get form a this person's
form b c d
yeah you got to have multiple different
tests so it's like no one you can't even
copy off each other because everyone's
test is different i still figured out a
way you did how did you do
you just started saying like if i got a
then you asked the person hey which one
did you get and then that's it
i think i got b i got i got four and b
yeah so then i'm going to cheat the
person in front of you oh hey they got
form c
what it was usually a b but i don't know
it's a b c b e f g
okay so you got to ask the person to
like eighth person down
you got a you know what people did uh at
ucla because it's bigger so there's like
300 kids
people would just leave straight up
books in the bathroom and you know you
go to the bathroom oh that's sick so
you're just going straight to the
bathroom like you you take the test out
until the last like 20 minutes
so all the questions you know that i
need to look up then you just go to the
bathroom and just
you take out like the book from the the
wax paper toilet covering thing
and you start looking through oh i was
just picturing it on the sink for
everyone to see
i don't know people are doing it
privately still no team no teamwork you
know what's crazy now too is
everyone's going back to school online
now right so it's like
wouldn't that make easy uh cheating
easier to yep like
people yeah but you're only taking it to
yourself
but you know though um so like if you
ever had to do
online traffic school yeah they time
your [ __ ] mm-hmm
[Music]
there are some that don't have clocks so
you can google which ones don't have
yeah clocks yeah i just recently did it
yeah i thought you said you just
cheated yourself i'm not cheating myself
from my time time is valuable time is
more valuable than cheating than a peso
for sure
yeah that's true one time 20 pesos i
wonder if the pesos converted to pesos
is different like mexican peso to
ecuadorian peso to filipino peso
to like spanish pesos i wonder if they
use pesos no
these euros never mind
so yeah so interestingly enough for the
women that were caught cheating
they were actually not barred from
taking the exam again they're like they
were allowed to come back better
and and and as long as you wear the
gloves you guys will be able to take the
test we forgive yeah i'm like what
that doesn't make any sense like doing
something like that would just mean
you're not ever going to be a teacher
ever again we're kind or or you like got
to do unpaid teaching for like five
years
and then you get like that's too asian
man you know it's funny
i i remember there was a there wasn't
too much pictures
that they would have like open book
tests yeah and and there was this other
teacher
that they allowed us to have like one
index card
and just write whatever the [ __ ] you
want on that one index card and you can
have it with you on the test
and i remember people were like
literally trying to jam-pack the entire
book into this one index card like front
and back
but and then the teacher is like haha
joke's on you because
as you're trying to write these answers
you're learning it all right jokes
that's the trick oh man i didn't realize
it's the reason why they give you that
index card i used to just write it and
then i take a post it and then i put it
on top as if it was a second layer
oh and you know you do you'd hole punch
this one they wouldn't allow you cards i
would hole punch a card and then i'll
put a rubber band on one end
and put the other rubber band right here
you [ __ ] magician right and then so
if my sleeve is down
you can pull the card out but if the
teacher walks by i could let go and i
was in my sleep
yeah you didn't do that i did do that
wait how did it stay like here though
like what was the mechanism like the
contraption
punch in a rubber band please damn
you're a loser dude
can we just use a different word you
keep
rubber band can this work if i punch to
hold my finger in this thing
you go here you can push this here all
right and as i hold this
okay so this is going to rip the [ __ ]
out of this oh okay that's pretty smart
dude this is gonna rip this
incredibly all right so this is how you
cheat i might need like a grommet to
like back up this
that's pretty good they're not gonna be
in classrooms for a while oh true true
so it'd be like this and then
hypothetically if this was strong enough
can't they hear like that oh yeah like
achoo you know what i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you